hi guys had another question from
someone that wanted to know if I have
know if I write she had it removed do I
have to take the thyroid hormone can I
just take iodine okay good question yes
you're gonna have to take it hormones
why because there's no other cell in the
body that can make thyroid hormones but
what I would do is I would recommend
getting with your doctor and making sure
that you monitor it so it's at a perfect
level maybe you want to look into
getting more of a natural complex like
arm or thyroid which is the kind of a
natural versus the synthetic synthroid
do research on that because the thyroid
does produce several different hormones
and you want to get the whole package
but what I would do is I wouldn't want
to ask why did you have it removed in
the first place was it a malignant
cancer they had to remove it and try to
do things to improve the reason why they
had to take it out in the first place
okay because that reason could be
affecting other parts of the body so if
it's cancer maybe you want to really
make sure that you consume a lot of
cruciferous vegetables but of course
that can inhibit thyroid hormones and
you might need to take more or maybe you
just add some sea kelp to counter that
but the benefits of cruciferous
vegetables for balancing estrogen are
very very important and of course keep
your diet really clean because with that
if I ride it puts a little stress on the
other glands and so you might need to be
even healthier to maintain your level of
health that you'd normally have alright
thanks for watching hey guys listen one
of the challenges people have is finding
specific answers to certain questions
because I have so many of videos okay
well I finally did it I bit the bullet
and I summarized every single video on
keto and fasting in one simple document
you just need to click the link below
and it'll upload messenger where you can
get an instant download okay check it
out